the Joe Rogan experience and hopefully
we'll be able to use these one like a
hundred times at least now is there any
innovation or any breakthroughs in fuel
and in the type of propulsion systems
that you need me no dude conceivably is
there ever going to be a time where we
have like a like a Star Wars ex fighter
that can just go shoot off onto its own
you know there's there's a potential for
more advanced more efficient thrust
engines and probably one of the most
promising ones in the near term is
actually a nuclear engine a nuclear
thermal rocket where you instead of
using combustion to propel hot gasses
out the back of your nozzle you have to
use a nuclear reactor and you take
hydrogen you flow it over that you heat
it up like super hot and shoot it out
the back without lighting it on fire and
if you do that you can actually get much
more thrust at with much less mass of
fuel like a smaller fuel tank but more
thrust over time so that's one possible
way to go so it's conceivable that one
day there could be a standalone unit
that doesn't need thrusters that eject
oh it still would look like a regular
rocket because the back of the head of
the nozzle would still have like fire
coming out the back but it would just be
superheated instead of letting him a
fire to heat it up you would you would
there you go there we go here nuclear
propulsion ntp nuclear thermal
propulsion so the top one is traditional
and the second one is the nuclear one
Wow yeah that's yeah so alright so there
it is that's the hydrogen coming in and
flowing over the reactor
instead of having liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen then you just all you
need is to liquid hydrogens Wow
so that's one way but in a short term
the advance you're seeing there with
that star hopper is that it's still a
traditional chemical propulsion rocket
so it's got fuel and oxidizer which is
liquid oxygen because no oxygen up there
to have fire you need the pyramid right
so you need the oxygen and the fuel and
the spark and you have to bring your own
oxygen if you're in space because you
can't use there you don't have that much
for anymore so to carry liquid oxygen
and some fuel and in the Falcon 9 for
exam
it's basically kerosene it's rocket fuel
but it's rp1 but it's basically kerosene
mixed with liquid oxygen the engine you
saw in that star hopper is advanced and
different because what it uses it still
uses liquid oxygen but instead of
kerosene it uses liquid methane and it's
actually not as efficient quite it
doesn't have that quite the specific
impulse which is a measure of efficiency
it doesn't have that quite as good as
hydrogen it's better than kerosene but
not quite as good as hydrogen but here's
a thing you can make it on Mars and
that's why we're that's why he lands
bill in that engine because you can go
to Mars and you don't have to bring your
gas to come home oh oh so that was the
big knock on going to Mars for the
longest time was that you'd never be
able to return you have to you have to
wait two years for the trajectory for
the plans to come back around so you
have a window that come home so you do
it to stay a while but that the
beautiful thing is if you can go
someplace and gas up again fill up your
tank without having to bring all the gas
with you that's huge right you can you
can be so much you can carry so much
more that way and and that's you can
with the carbon dioxide that's in the
Martian atmosphere and the water that's
in the ice that's on the surface of Mars
you can have a reaction a process by
that allows you to create to take those
two things and make liquid methane and
you can have the tanker that ready to go
and all done robotically you can get the
telemetry back saying we've got the gas
and then you go now how much are things
can accelerate now that you have all
these different companies competing
against each other that's what's
beautiful is is like the pace of
technological changes like really going
exponential again just kind of like it
was during Apollo so we're back onto
that really rapid that fast track we
kind of fell off of that for a little
while and the nice thing about people
ask me like what's the biggest
difference between working on SpaceX and
working at NASA and I would say beta its
decision speed because well we'll make
up our mind quickly now the reason we
can do that is we got a tremendous
amount of agility because sometimes when
you make up your mind quickly you make
the wrong decision right yeah but if you
hurry up and figure out that you made
the wrong decision and you have the
agility to then say okay that was not
right let's try not something else
then it works at NASA you know we had
all these contractors and suppliers and
and a very cumbersome kind of system
that we took a long time to make sure we
made the right decision because changing
things was prohibitively costly mm-hmm
but SpaceX doesn't have to worry about
that oh now what is differentiating the
way SpaceX is handling it you said
Boeing has something what did they call
it again so nASA has Commercial Crew
program and they selected two commercial
companies to partner with SpaceX and
Boeing and so's Boeing is using you know
an older rocket that's been around a
long time called the Atlas 5 and they
built a capsule to go on top of that
called the Starliner and so this is
strictly for commercial flights well it
mean it's for its that that the the
anchor tenant if you will that the core
customer is still NASA because NASA is
going to use both of these rockets to
replace the space shuttle and we won't
have to beg the Russians for rides
anymore hmm let me see what the Boeing
one looks like what's the name of it
again a star liner or used to be called
that cst-100 let me see what this sucker
looks so I'll just call it the POS one
hundred is you know eating but but it's
a good ride it's a good vehicle okay so
it's kind of similar in its design a
little bit it's the way it look well
it's pretty dope yeah one key difference
is it lands we splashed down in the
water and this one lands on land with
those air bags
oh wow yeah what if those bags don't
work so is it is it fill up like the way
they use Rovers on Mars where it's
surrounded by these gigantic air bags
and bounces when it hits the ground it
doesn't bounce because that's not good
for people robots don't mind but if you
bounce like that you're gonna be really
upset so it just hits and kind of like
airbags that deploy in a car and they
deflate and then you're done and so this
is on the same sort of timeline as the
spacex ship yeah I think they're there I
think SpaceX specs test is really ready
to go like in March like very soon but I
think we're gonna wait a little longer
because they're talking about extending
the mission for Bob and Doug and keeping
them on the space station so they need
more training sorry
yeah well they get to get to hang out in
space for a while I'm not - I don't feel
too bad for him and their equipment is
keeping them from losing all the bone
density and muscle and everything yeah
they'll be fine now when does Elan go to
space oh wow I mean how well do you have
to have the system working before you
put the boss in the capsule
shoot him off into the heavens he's got
a lot of work to do here so I don't
think he's going to any time soon but he
does eventually when when we get this up
and running he does eventually want to
go he talks about he wants to die on
Mars just not all tactful you know that
the that jokey kiss so that's that's you
know he's serious about that he really
does want to die on Mars like really old
he wants to go and live the rest of his
days as part of a permanent Martian
colony Oh
Elon I got to talk to you about this but
he's not going to tell he always thought
that way yeah that's always been the
plants always been a plan maybe we can
get him high again reconsiders seems
like a terrible idea
well he's gonna wait he's not gonna be
the first one he's gonna wait until we
have like pieces airing some couch Ino
and like a decent hotel
[Applause]